hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast promise and challenges of
ips modeling and Parkinson's disease I
am soon fam a blog roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's session
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots believing social
scientific networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you today by
cellulitis cellular dynamics
international is a leading developer of
fully functional human cells derived
from induced pluripotent stem cells or
iPS cells our I cell and my cell
products provide industrial qualities of
high and industrial quantities of high
quality highly pure human cells enabling
disease modeling drug discovery toxicity
testing and cell therapy research for
more information please visit www our
dynamics com now let's get started you
can post questions any time during the
presentation during while they're fresh
in your mind to do so simply type them
in the green Q&A box which will open
when you click the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window questions will be answered after
the presentation to enlarge the slide
window click on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have problems viewing or
seeing the presentation just click on
the support button that's found at the
top right of the presentation window or
type them in the green Q&A button on the
lower left corner this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located at the bottom left corner of
your web page and follow up the process
of obtaining your credits I would like
now to present today's speaker dr. Barry
at shul dr. period she will obtain her
medicine and her doctoral degrees at the
George August university in Kotkin and
medical university Lynn lubick Germany
the shul worked during her neural
neurological internship at the Medical
University lubeck with dr. Christine
Klein on genetic forms of Parkinson's
disease and dystonia she also completed
a pox
postdoctoral fellowship in the
laboratory of dr. Udo Frankie department
of genetics at stanford university
school of medicine before joining the
Parkinson's institute in october 2005
doctor xu l leads the genetic and
biomarker program since 2008 she has
built a stem cell program developing
novel disease in a dish model of
parkinson's disease using
patient-derived induced pluripotent stem
cells in 2014 she became the director of
the brain bank at the Parkinson's
Institute I will now turn it over to dr.
birgit for period she will for her
presentation thank you so much for the
introduction thanks for CDI for
sponsoring is some lecture and I'm
really excited to get this presentation
I know my lab ism joining me also and be
sitting next door in a conference room
so let's get started because if you
don't know the Parkinson's Institute we
are in the San Francisco Bay Area that
in CT was founded in nineteen
eighty-eight by dr. James Louie Langston
also called billings them and be
exciting part of the institute is that
we have a clinical Center who have about
1500 applications a basic research
laboratory and clinical research all
under one roof so it's very easy to
conduct translational studies so that's
why we have large t-shirt biospecimen
resources like the reclamation program
the blue genetics program or also the
stencil program which we started to
establish in 2008
so let me start with blood is
Parkinson's disease the textbook
definition of Parkinson's disease is
that it's a slowly progressive
degenerative disorder characterized by
motor symptoms of rigor tremor and by
using impacts about one to two percent
of the population of the age of 60 and
pathological you'll find a lot of
children and ignorance and the brainstem
k teristic protein inclusions known as
we buddies and those we buddies
curtained of hoping that's called a
facility and research has been done over
the last almost 20 years to figure out
what alpha-synuclein does you find
whatever set here and we buddies and
this is an alpha cen including staying
in 1997 soon after the gene was
discovered as the first caused of you
for familial Parkinson's disease so
again the clinical aspects are resting
tremor radhika iniya stiffness postural
instability and the phenomenon called
freezing so patients can't initiate the
next step for example though can work
through a doorway yourself now here you
see a panel how the disease is
progressing over the years usually
patients come within a year to a
neurologist and get the diagnosis when
the medication is working fine there's
the 325 here harmoo period were no
patients do pretty well that follow
that's followed by a motor complication
period whether medications not working
so well and you have a website check for
example disk a museum some point and the
symptoms become resistant to medication
and then late stages there's also a
cognitive become imperially
so I'm some of you might have heard
earlier today dr. Carlson from Sweden
but just to give you some history about
the global efficiency and partly
Pendleton so dr. Carlson did some
reading several experiments and he
turned out that Lieber go full reverse
Radhika media and mice and rabbits that
he fingered with reserving and he
speculated that dopamine deficiency
causes typing concerns she proposed I
but early on people didn't quite
understand because they bought that
building a mistress a precursor and you
are a mere considering the brain look it
was proved to be right and he won the
Nobel price in two thousand this is just
one of them make sure is from his and
his publication work he had reserved
been treated animals and then after they
were treated with bilbo and the symptoms
gross that's quite exciting that was
picked up pretty quickly by only twenty
cubits and showed that in the striatum
in the brainstem of Parkinson's patients
is actually all the patient like
dopamine and these early doctors Barbara
grab my ammonia hearings and katsu as
they treated and soon after patients
with l-dopa and saw a dramatic effect
among are conducted the first clinical
trial and the effects were so dramatic
and despite the dyskinesia that they
already noted at that kinda our local
received regulatory approval and became
really the main treatment of Parkinson's
disease in the maladies oh missing
something in this picture
this is a case history from a patient at
dr. Langston son about ten years ago and
it is 70 year old man could end with a
15-year history of chronic constipation
so he aspired lost a sense of smell we
also develop an unusual sleep disorder
and he was hitting his wife because he
has bigger dreams and he had several
episodes of depression in the past so
none of the typical clinical motor
symptoms and were preventing that these
are symptoms that are also associated
with Parkinson's disease and they're
called cream or normal symptoms of the
disease plea because they can occur
before the motor symptoms arise and as I
said no motor because they are not
affecting needles it's all factions
function depression and the sleep
parties we have ambers REM disorder and
then decides the constipation there
could be also other autonomic
disturbances and like gustaria
innovation hypertension urinary or
erectile dysfunction the patient and to
keep and as i said earlier later stage
is also positive indication so there
there are her legs and the brain and
that you can achieve these four so for
example they don't doctor discussion you
can see note that control is effective
for depression raphe nuclei and other
areas in the brain run disorder in the
coeruleus are normally disturbances you
tribute that two changes are you
sympathetic ganglia men show great loss
hallucinations so as I can show you it's
not just the succession either that's
effective but also various other frames
so and just to tell you that this is not
something that has just recently that
become apparent already hungry TV back
then in 1912 reportedly buddies not in
the substantia [ __ ] but in these other
Brandon Lewis for example a bore so
useful not only present Vegas with this
is a designer and hyper Valerie's is not
reporting the substantial a growth in
1928 another during pathologist hair so
reportedly buddies in the sympathetic
ganglia so we know about this phenomena
all the way since its beginnings that I
guess the dopamine discovery was so so
profound that we might have forgotten
those those early discoveries labor van
for Montgomery buddies in the esophagus
in 1984 1988 rock rock about now she
reportedly buddies in the low a costly
fun so already a very solid information
that there's my pathology grown in the
succession neither this is a slide from
the best sir hi quick drop in front /
and he saw the new body pathology and
renew rights we're in the stomach all
occasions
okay so I think what I produced you
about is that Parkinson's not only
affects the substantia [ __ ] is also
priming more on the loss and other areas
like the door you know dig locus
coeruleus doukas azalea's of minor
ralphing repairs those are not dopamine
loop systems and movie buddies have been
found in the same variance and I think
we we figured a lot of things out
clinically and pathologically however
there is from the study in 2014 from the
Arizona right aging in the began to
order a paper that says there's really
no clinical diagnostic accuracy of
hypothesis is quite devastating you can
see the numbers here only ten percent
twenty-six percent accuracy for clinical
diagnosis of Parkinson's analogy that or
not clearly we would open responsive
subjects
the Diagnostics got a little better and
when people all responsive to medication
Rice's 250 p % and then I think
relations get pretty good when there's a
lot of distillation when the patient's
was going wrote illegal doper than
yogurt was a greater than practicing
diagnostic accuracy in summary we can
say as Parkinson's disease is a complex
disorder and known as the textbook
definition the beginning is from trying
to the substantial manga and that too
many different areas so would like to
call the Parkinson's disease now we
notice system commun body issues and
this is from a review that we
unproductive late last year and may
continue so it's part of existing that
accepts the question I'll get all trains
from patients don't you see mccormick
that about one percent of patients with
parkinson's disease record a family
history and since the discovery of of
semi-clean alpha-synuclein in 1997 and
if they now over 30 jeans a risk factor
and have them attributed to parkinson's
disease so either by linkage studies and
Emily's likes on sequencing or by
genome-wide Association studies
the concern here is that maybe you know
all of those feelings actually cause
Parkinson's disease and rather than a
form of clinical parkinsonism because
some of those low say that are better
described here we don't show any new
body pathology which means that I've
highlighted snca so focus a nuclear
window are two and also on this item TBA
are reaching is there this common and
the result in a single death is really
closely related to system Parkinson's
disease look at this a little closer and
also to visualize that because in the
table and things become more equal what
I was trying to do is to draw a a a
table and graph and I wanted to
illustrate how close and are the other
dramatic forms to may be empathic our
consistency so Parkinson's disease is
represented here on the x-axis you see
maybe call chemical distance it's
including mr. of different clinical
symptoms and on the y-axis I was
plotting the age at onset the different
colors represent them the anybody
pathology so bu is typical anybody
pathology and on yellow and orange are
is where this fear no information about
any pathology already know you probably
found the size of the circle really
represents the prevalence and this is
just relative because Parkinson's
disease sporadic things are over ninety
percent so weak you still looking at
least or what you can see them is that
really only like two jbag
and of the same band are the ones that
come closest clinically and your
pathological capacity and son right what
I wanted to convey is that there are
many areas in the central and peripheral
nervous system that are affected besides
the your budget system is also the more
deluded or not you can certain unique
system of pepper genetics gives us the
opportunity to understand the disease
but then the challenge is also that the
right mount st. the syndromes together
that should be classified and we that
encourages today then more discoveries
coming on way I hope and only three
genes like to GBA and also say Ukraine
really cause I'm not economy Multi multi
system for disease
so now I'm coming to modeling
Parkinson's disease and what is the
right model to find these disease
mechanisms these cells possibly for
discovering so I was listing here all
the key under I sell your models are
available and where people get to play
worker so you can start with finally
patient-derived cell lines like
fibroblast eating you transform rympha
loss of cell range silent cell lines and
there is the category of human here
blastoma or other carcinoma cells and
NGC model are also immortalized human
nevin cephalic and cell rings and then
come one of the most famous one is the
ministering and then now they are stem
cells that we can use for magazine
disease very mad ish orbitals and for
summer placement or also understand
let's just illustrate some how a human
model and play using English for people
stem cells from patients with
parkinson's disease and it's a it's a
cycle that 80 so you learn on a clear
night on the biopsy use an extern
culture to bang some of those fiberglass
and then you say technology called
epigenetic reprogramming and and you
will receive purple to Spencer condition
not a Parkinson's you want then to
differentiate those souls into worms and
then you have really a wide variety of
what you can google sells these research
look screening genetics or developmental
biology the other approach that people
also use as to try to use mousse purple
stem cells or similar and stem cell
types
or sacrifices
so this is how you can envision modeling
Parkinson's English making a biopsy for
the patient use them to program them
with federal factors and then do
directional differentiation to study
disease mechanisms or unnecessary
conduct clinical trials English this in
some 2008-2009 we derived over a beast
in cell lines yet to institute we have
over 100 useful in stem cell lines from
those and the stable you see a different
dramatic forms of the disease we have
alpha synuclein and you see mark to
which we have really most of your most
of the cases you have some rare friends
or the taxon or 22q11 deletion I also
want to add that we recently started a
program where we were on now collecting
ninja cells which could also be another
way to really look at IPS cells that
come from pathologically including
Parkinson's disease so this just is a a
nice overview and entities are watching
tonight who with this type of research
and I wanted to show you that we used a
patient who is descending from the Iowa
cubed and has been solid at Mayo Clinic
for over 100 years it's a very strong
family will stream is family and it's a
very early onset so the typical onset is
not in the 30s and parkinson's disease
from South Korea and I'm assessing the
pathologically we have blueberry
pathology and this is really all over
the book playing including the context
so in this case look and dou by
singleton found in 2003 this is a family
that has a trick vacation or throughout
the cemetery milkers and that is the
people here on this to say and copy
number in the message when you see a
action three copies of action over range
on 1.7 megabases not the same you clean
this human to it so in fact what you
have been in the cells are four copies
of us anything three copies from this
case pending determination and I extend
it on on the right side here pedigree
under the patient that can actually
following of this one here we have
parkinson's disease emphasis and start
the dilation in sudden your community so
we'll be using were able to undo my
fibroblasts we created IPS lines we
studied your precursor lines from psych
yourself and then we looked at clinic at
Eleanor phenotypes and become profound
magnetic or your your type and increases
of people looking to oxidative stress
and this has been published love
anything
ooh
well I want to talk a little bit about
the challenges of outlaws normally if
you're working with tissue who the hell
multiple donors will create in the dish
multiple IPS cries and you create also
when the differentiating different types
of neurons become these different
differentiation notes so i wouldn't
illustrate what are these you should
consider when you're working and IPS
lines and were the challenges so one is
the background a petition going so
number one what's the source open a
tissue each gender ethnicity it is means
that's let go and it is presenting with
underlying disease causing equation but
also overall some genetic background and
possibly romantic novels clinical
manifestation your pathology if you have
environmental exposure and also how do
you rifles some subcultures so what
we've started and we have nine on five
lines of those because we're interested
in the mere cathartic your pathology
meshing meshing with our donors we were
collecting ninjas from our brain bellies
with confirmed anybody technology so
this is what you see the system use of
communities and in each other he sells
better growing out of a station this is
17 days later and going to commend those
cells and they can grow their nasal
Concha
the other area where you can see a lot
of variability is the nuclear
reprogramming process and it's very
exciting to see that this method is
working but it also gets quite
complicated so you can use integrating
methods you can use normally grading
methods and originally women drive out
those lines we use the Yemen are
protectors on lentivirus system and
since we do not want to have an
integrate and integration in the genome
we are no using some my values as a non
integrating it but they're all other
different points around we'll use mrna
we will use them in circles the only
thing proteins also going to make
increments so and it's really okay to
the user which system to use but i guess
the equalization is that you want to be
because of neuronal differentiation is
there are also lots of options so
originally we 15 years ago people use
for heinous differentiation of stem
cells until arrived neurons then in
early two thousand there was a whole
culture like the strongest girls layers
cost called STI a journal writing using
activity you can pre cultures and
countries cells and astrocytes was an
android body differentiation on in the
sphere information methods out there it
is differentiation using small molecule
inhibitors or recombinant proteins or
you can also engineer your cell lines to
express certain whip rain factors can
differentiate and push those cells
towards the region image so i think most
of the most of the labs that i've been
working with are now using on what's
your under number five so the
differentiation using email KZ
monarchical inhibitors or pecan cookies
and this is just an example of how you
can rise I'm very nice doping your
ignorance you see here under PE okay
baby so they're staying with th they go
through a face and a flow progenitors
where they express you be high level and
high levels of peroxide to expression
riches this I'm not even hungry family
in general I want to note that there is
also very bility in general culture good
conditions so you should look at the
seating densities passage number are you
on your passes yourselves if you do it
manually and automatically what media
you use can make a huge difference
exercise I on a tricks where should
using by the preservation even plastic
writing should make sure that s
consistent behind you don't have
mentions them and effect culture and the
faulty other culture ok in summary the
challenges and the solution half here is
you should take a look at systematic
collection and documentation of your
patients you want to collect matching
controls you want to dramatically
characterize your subjects and patients
and if you have a chance we might also
want to generate genetically engineered
I so Jenny Jones then in terms of ips
derivation United you some system
methods when use consistent consumer
goods and with other cell line you want
to make sure that the karyotype is
changing and can capture all Diesel's
granvia for the neural depreciation
consistent methods are key you also you
want to have an unbiased
characterization can kind wishes of your
cell type of interest for example the
number of different engineering and the
mid friends are sophisticated as you
want to make sure that so is it possible
logically acting ok i'm showing you here
and very interesting study that we build
if we do the work
look at two other groups after three
other groups of seminole biosciences
it's a group around in B minor and all I
system and so we were using gene editing
and patient-derived and useful purpose
themselves to look at a specific human
kind that's caused by our communications
so we first saw is in this essay that
Morris embers develop is that we have
microbial DNA damage in cells that carry
our communications with science she
surveys SI needless sa the polymerase
that she's using would not an uncle Tai
temple as quickly when there is
mitochondrial DNA damage compared to a
special that's so what you have here is
you have on XX sister different clothes
that we've used and then ND y axis a
number of regions for uncle basil she
noted so c 1 2 3 are and cocaine so this
very little neither padres game i vanish
but then when we are going interview I
guess the right neurons for patients
with our communications I learn to three
with a in 2019 orientation see increased
9 delusions which is also true for this
second our communication or 140 wanna
see we compared the mitochondrial DNA
copy number but those were definitely on
similar across lines so that was not the
reason that we have here and coming in
south of using offenses that are he was
fighting tonight
so then I said okay it's an interesting
it's an interesting phenomenon but is
this relating to this one equation that
we think of and so the use and thinks
finger nuclease at that time and
nowadays you also want to use crisp herb
which is some little easier to design an
EXO and more economical but the concept
is the same so basically the same thing
a nuclear is is like a miraculous
scissor and you can create a double
strand cuffs and then depending if you
have a large and owner you can and
should use modular ethical hair and
actually incorrect imitation or if you
don't have a donor the fair will prepare
the bike itself and through North
America's and joining but that process
is prone to error and in some cases
innovation to use smaller lesions or
also insertions so that's a way to
create them knockout mountains for
example and i'll show you here is this
is the design for the sister finger
design pieces here and the donor that
the instantaneous have interesting me
excited mutation that mean produce as a
restriction site to do how about that
was quite an elegant of a chef from the
make our scientists develop difficult
this is the time the result of our um ji
an Athenian yourself and don't look a
single cable is the modification it will
be received on regression in this case
on Orioles alpha is that we authorized
nah no I'm really nervous enjoying on
the belt up earlier don't have hormones
and John Anthony bit earlier
then for some you couldn't write a big
girl english usually Awards I know we
also have by American on my knees and
joints or we created some rhymes they're
actually a bio not or else about
anything amending the system i said and
done I was modified all of the lines
show some steak I'm not a fan oh sorry
you didn't picture myself so here's know
the experiment done that I showed you on
the mega corner of the enemy vanish and
in this case we compare under our to
Boonton cellar which is here too now the
rectus are two line which is now out of
all time and on panel a me up here we
did this essay this is our essay in self
derive from no projectors or atmosphere
and software prolific and down here
Hughes differentiated nouns that happen
how the portion of th Uranus but also
and a different wings it's not a
complete that you will get torture but
it also seemed that at the increase in
myocardial in illusions ending life was
when you correct with the gene
engineering approach you see basically
no I'm crime with more engaging
what we've also done is we've repeated
those experiments um in Sector lab in
the middle different methodology so we
worked with Isis and and other printed
time and Argo repeated those experiments
were able to help employers as well that
was a nice confirmation this is a little
random so overall we have in life 2 20
million s mutations and I become your
eternal I have you shown you all of the
data we have some additional hassles
that affection that we've seen that like
to and also increase in myocardial
damage and with a finger modification we
were able to reverse that my deployment
language in this case we were able to
consistently replicate these results so
we have different donors or people's
you've seen in the first she's likes use
different IPS see feelings and got some
our results we use in this case
different neuronal differentiation
protocols replicate the result when
ultimately we were able to confirm that
phenotype using asian collection so that
was a very nice from information and and
validation I just normally actually
helps us understand and gun now coming
to the end of my presentation and then
if you're interested in this and going
share this you have a log that shows how
to take your fibroblast fermentation in
this case of Alex you had very early
onset disease to a 36 is diagnosed bill
may be concise and she is some in
dialogue with us
he learns how this themselves it turns
into stem cells and how we differentiate
yourself visit our blog and also visit
us she unearthed and put it on them Alan
think everyone has participated and
these studies first of all and I think
all the patients and barn piastre put in
skin game and think former lab members
to help setting up and reading at the
lab building the IPS bank and during the
early studies with me Colonel at member
services here agent hora para Jimmy and
calcium nada watching absorb and I'm
very thankful for being part of the
clinical center of the Parkinson's
Institute and dr. Lisa and dr. Kahn
garlic and more support as are all
clinicians and cake and then on the
right side here I have highlighted the
folks at sunderland it's working
aggressively and McLean Hospital hybrid
University who helped I'm yes I'm using
finger motor argument support canary on
from the blue carnation and in sheboygan
sequence coughing Institute and Davis
first big plan to and jump starting an
IPS gem and we also have the Parkinson's
Alliance you're helpless and this means
our infamous research
that's all thank you I'll colossally on
down man we're ready for questions it is
lonely i guess i'm reading the question
yourself as you will able to see a
phenotype and learns that have been
derived from I pcs from both run Pegasus
I guess who looks for attic and familiar
fun so that's a very good question and
because right forms as they showed you
don't have the typical typical mutations
that described in the lumen amenities
and we personally have not dealt
emergency sporadic parkinson's disease
it seems a little bit more complicated
and go to the variation but I they are
some papers out there that found found
common phenotypes between normal and
sporadic things next question is have
you looked at we looked at functional
endpoints to assess mankind relativity
and guns and so anything looks like a
must ose found out here I have to see
how with the family and look at social
endpoints assess my productivity and
lines you see differences between
controlling new patients yes we've done
it looked at 9.2 the canburger sir nice
paper that Edwin published in 2014 and
+1 we are looking at changes for example
Michael an NGO transition pore I
Department membrane potential of them as
you using differences the earlier
presented like to vacation line that
study using the precursors valuation are
you planning on expanding your students
to other patients with some other type
of these petitions and the answer is yes
I am I'm coming and playing you're not
alone yourself from mutations and
Fabregas signs you see has some rare new
patients that can also calls into system
anybody disease example the 22q11
deletion we've just recently followed a
patient who have an attacks and an
expansion which has never been
associated buckle Parkinson's disease
unfortunately we don't have the
pathology undead so next question that
this correction be applied to animal
models so I believe you're referring to
the direction of the Lark to these
weren't to make an education I believe
so um the thing I technology and other
do editing technologies or no please
also to UM to create them motivated so
and pretty sure that your pipe you
describe to diverse a specific
population of cells are affected by mu
bunch of Parkinson's disease what are
the self have in common that renders
them boil condition at occasions
that's a little discussion mmm and and I
probably don't have the answer here I'm
nine for the reference profitable
relativity in a Buick neurons in the
substantia [ __ ] is that a project to
the striatum and they have a lot of
connections in the striatum so when both
we learn and connect up to 135 thousand
and neurons in any English rally in the
other one doesn't cost a lot of Brandon
sees so um go about 100 to 200 nights in
Europe trade own and can be overlapping
and and exhilarating so I don't know
this answer but it's very good question
so I mean one way with me to either
differentiate not only building
materials but also in order to know Jake
with certain ignorance for like this
noise or the opposite you could do is
you can generate a on a more generic
we're on in dish and then I see water
what's common continues to be but it's a
it's a very interesting question okay so
works loved ones and all of the
questions so much guys for the damage
guys for a change Thank You Bridget that
was a fantastic presentation and great
job answering the questions and great
questions from the audience too if there
are no more questions I would like once
again to thank dr. shuo for such a
fantastic presentation give any final
comments for us before we part I'm quite
excited about this type of education and
training I mean not everyone can attend
attend conferences this is a way to to
learn about in science I myself sign up
for another two lab routes and webinars
so I'm quite excited about this for
night although it's a little hard to
connect with the audience but I guess
anything to it needs to live will be so
much well you did a fantastic job and
thank you again to the audience for
joining us today and for some really
interesting questions we would also like
to thank our sponsor cellular dynamics
for bringing today's educational webinar
to you guys this webcast can be viewed
on demand through September 2016 library
tool there you via email when it's ready
for replay and we really encourage you
to share that email with your colleagues
whom and miss today's live event until
next time bye bye